they stole it and this they do
supposedly in the name of Jewish people
Palestine has been an Arab Muslim
country and it was thriving this whole
notion that there was nothing there is
complete fabrication and not only it's a
Fabrication in 1948 when the Zionist
conquered Palestine they stole it they
stole like I said the produce from the
fields they stole money in the banks
there were Banks people had money in the
banks people were working people there
was an economy they stole millions of
dollars worth of money they stole cars
they stole buildings Hospital entire
cities can you imagine they come in they
kick out the people and there are cities
but it's very clear that this there's a
complete Fabrication in order to justify
the crime of theft and killing and this
they do supposedly in the name of Jewish
people